here are this week's top movies I got a  big secret I was the star witness  against the mob in just getting started  friendly rivals team up to stop a  murderous threats early everyone has  their own truth the true story of an  abuse survivor who becomes a top-level  ice skater before falling from grace is  told in AI Tonya she's someone coming in  or out of the lab in 1962 two women  discover a shocking secret experiment at  a government laboratory in the shape of  water he's coming to see what's hot in  theaters with this week's fantasy  patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]